excuse me Jeff but this is an old friend
of mine John Watson why can I borrow
your phone I'm sorry I left mine in my
coat oh here here's mine oh thank you
Joe's looking for a roommate also you
could stay with your brother
I suppose if his aggressive drinking
didn't bother you so much
excuse me your brother he's an alcoholic
who recently walked out on his wife I
don't even know your name you just met
me how could you possibly know if I have
a brother or if he left his wife
engraving the engraving on your phone
Harry Watson a family member but not
your father that's a young man's gadget
it could be a cousin but you're a war
hero can't find a place to live unlikely
you've got an extended family so brother
it is how could you possibly know about
the drinking shot in the dark
good one though power connection tiny
little scuff marks are on the edge of it
every night he goes to plug into charge
but his hands are shaking you'll never
see those marks on a sober man's phone
never see a drunks without them good
lord that's remarkable and completely
wrong what everything you said was wrong
you're saying that I'm that I was wrong
nothing you said was correct everything
I said was correct no this is my dad's
fault but that's a young man's gadget it
it's my dad's he gave it to me when you
upgraded what about the scratches on the
phone don't mean anything they're just
scratches on a phone it's a very small
hole sometimes people have trouble
plugging you did yeah don't drink a drop
and I have the same scratches well then
I can tell by the yellow markings on
your jacket sleeve you had a sandwich
for lunch messy mustard deli on what I
want to say was rye bread the common
choice for a man dressed as well as you
are white bread far too common with
someone who selects such well hemp
trousers with I would say Turkey honey
it's smoked yet the discoloration in
your eyes leads me to believe you have a
vitamin b12 deficiency the vitamin most
easily found in meat so I'd rather say
honey smoked tofu as you are and have
always been a vegetarian
nope pardon not a vegetarian as a matter
of fact I'd soup for lunch which is
pretty much the exact opposite of a
sandwich
wait even I knew here soup because I
could smell it on it shut the mic right
well it was a pleasure meeting you
oh wait before you go why don't we sit
down for a spot of tea no thank you the
twitching your brows betrayed you you
are a coffee drinker I prefer tea just
not thirst homeschools London central
heavy smoker never in my life
heterosexual I curious lack what you are
a black man no black woman really [ __ ]
oh oh hey hey Amy no sheesh listen Laura
say you want to go look at some flats
let's go look at some flats yes I found
a great listening for something on Baker
Street not for the dog and pony show
yeah great great great you blink
approximately every 12.2 seconds trade
of someone uncomfortable with extended
silence leaving you to believe that you
came from a noisy household parents
fighting no squabbling regularly but
your shoulders are relaxed leading me to
believe you had an extracurricular
activity to blow off steam while you've
had since childhood but look not a
strong upper body so I'll say dance at
first simple sachets foxtrots but you
needed more didn't you that's when you
met the b-boys mastered the robot the
lawnmower the fish additionally the way
you grip your cane suggests a high
degree of martial arts training your tan
implies you recently fought and we tie
tournament in Singapore but your knees
are hyper-extended not strength so you
flew business class the in-flight movie
was Madagascar to escape to Africa you
liked it but didn't love it naturally
the flight attendant Trish offered you
pretzels or peanuts
you chose peanuts but the sadness in
your eyes reveals that you regretted it
immediately after
yes really really you really are a
master of deductions oh thank god
wait a minute you're just saying that to
make me feel better yes
aha I caught you in a lie I knew it you
were placating me yes boom Wow that's
how you deduce baby
I read your face I think your stupid
face yeah suck it the name by the way
is her LOC Shone's isn't it Sherlock
Holmes shut up Mike